we have a clear understanding of what
their capabilities are and we've studied
their doctrine for a long time their
decision making on the part of the
president that's another factor
you know whether or not they would do
something or would not do something
i think
the lesson learned here is you can't
predict
what a
dictator might do
you have to respect the capabilities
that they have and you have to be ready
to respond yeah they know that's what's
happening because marines like all other
folks follow news they're following it
closely so they know i think their
training here in other words is
heightened in terms of its relevance
because something is actually going on a
conflict a war they have they know they
must be ready yes
it's really cool to see kind of how
ukraine is a small country with not
really that big of an army has taken on
the behemoth that's called russia
and how they've kind of just set their
will to fight
and how that really works people
actually want to be there want to defend
their home country they will
that's inspiring to see it's inspiring
to see because we're
norway we don't have the biggest
military
but i think if russia came
we would have the
what you call a courage we will fight
for ourselves
well uh the russian military has done
much worse than expected they have taken
very little land in the few weeks that
they've been in ukraine
and i think it probably has to do with
the
leadership and
many of the soldiers going into ukraine
don't know what they're going into
they're not fighting a war they want to
win they're fighting a war
their country i sent them into without
any choice